Freddie Gibbs I'm on the bootleg Kev
podcast talking about everything talking
about your mama boy
that's bootleg Capt show
special guest
one of my best friends my good friend
who may have the album of the year
coming out on September 30th [ __ ]
we're just gonna say it here we're gonna
make the official Proclamation the album
of the Year already Seoul sold
separately
September 30th
Mr Frederick Gibbs thank you how you
doing how you doing Kevin this is a this
is a [ __ ] experience I can cussed on
this [ __ ] yeah of course okay I thought
your [ __ ] was
going to be on the rate I mean extra
white extra listen spicy white Kevin
White he's spicy White
you know someone told that he got spices
his wife Mexican [ __ ] or Ecuador one of
them she's Mexican she's Mexican okay
she said that uh that [ __ ] got that
[ __ ] got spikes there's a YouTube
comment on a video we just released and
it said Kev is the grain of salt that
made it through in the pepper packet
yeah wow what's that mean that that mean
you made it in man yeah I guess I don't
know you did something man like God say
all you need is the faith of a [ __ ]
Mustard Seed [ __ ]
well uh first of all I want to shout you
out because you uh you were the first uh
episode that we ever did of the Bublé
cat podcast oh [ __ ] popped off the whole
[ __ ] man so that's that [ __ ] crazy
because I've been seeing I watched the
blue leg kill podcast all the time and
I'll be looking at the Young [ __ ] and
I'd be like damn I'm not doing that [ __ ]
so I appreciate this podcast because
this show a lot of young [ __ ] and what
not to do 100 man well welcome uh look
so sold separately
it's been two years since alfredo two
years and a couple months yeah about
that yeah about that yeah uh I wasn't
gonna drop my album this year really I
was gonna let it all like ride out let
it play out and let everybody else kind
of drop the album and stuff like
you know I was like I was like listening
to albums and stuff and then I was just
I got bored it's been a pretty subpar
hip-hop year you think so there's been
like the top tier [ __ ] is great like I
love the jid album Kendrick album was
great the Pusha T album is great uh
there's some great [ __ ] Denzel Curry's
albums though but I just feel like in
terms of like I think it drops off like
after like maybe six or seven projects
in terms of just like
I feel like a couple of years ago it was
like damn there's like 10 11 12 projects
that could be album of the year but like
I feel like this year it's very like top
heavy if that makes sense like titty
heavy like big titties and like the game
got titties and no ass right now that's
basically what you're saying the game
like hip hop yeah yeah okay yeah okay
it's real top heavy it's top heavy it
ain't really it ain't it ain't really uh
spread across the board come here man
come here come here just bring it you
got this you gotta rabbit in the
building just bring your ass in here man
come on
what's this you want this yes yes Sour
Patch Sour Patch Kids for the children
you're about to be in a dentist
rocking with this your teeth you're
gonna have like a whole bunch of silver
teeth you're gonna have teeth like
Spencer yeah
[Music]
by the way Lambo when Spencer gets here
he's gonna hit you up so you could go a
little man
he's gonna be here in like five minutes
go see uh Max and Lambo okay Daddy gotta
finish let's go all right nice uh nice
appearance by a little man nice
appearance yeah he could have them
um
but it's crazy because like obviously
you've been taking your time at this
project your first album on Warner
you've been throwing out singles right
last couple of years
um
I know that we're getting this snuck in
like right before the Grammy
considerations are cut off for the year
I'm sure yeah it was on purpose
hey champ eat your candy and chill out
I don't care about the Grammy man give
me dad of the Year man it's hard job
being a rapper and being a dad man yeah
nah but uh yeah we did that on purpose
because I mean of course you know once
you get considered
foreign
go outside you can hang out in there and
go outside on TV you tripping
that's not you want to throw something
on the uh the computer from just YouTube
or something on the studio computer just
won't let me be great at all man
it's all good man I'm surprised when I
did that uh that the one freestyle that
he sat still that whole time but I was
about to beat his ass though
right before I had to like be like hey
man you better chill dog he was like
much smaller yeah I know he now he just
got to mind his own he was like then he
was like two now he's like four and he's
just well four-year-olds are like
they're like little men yeah he not
stopping talking he's like yo you don't
care if he gotta say something he's
saying it out loud he's not a Whisperer
at all so yeah shout out to uh first of
all what is like for you being a father
obviously you you know you have uh
you have always kind of stood on like
being a good dad which is something that
like we don't see a lot in hip-hop like
you always make sure that you you get
your kids no matter what the situation
is with the moms you know what I'm
saying like
yeah yeah you got to do what you got to
do you know what I mean and you know
shout out to their moms you know I mean
their moms you know you know they they
are they all good women it's all it's
all smooth you know anything you know
that you uh got that you love is gonna
be complications with it so you know
it'd be like that you know but everybody
you know really own you know got the
same general Mission you feel me 100
um so back to this album man
I've heard a lot of iterations of the
album there was some music that didn't
make the album that we'll talk about why
it didn't make the album but
um because there's some there's some
stories that we'll get to there a lot of
stories of this album I feel like this
album was like a
like like a whole nother like comic book
you know what I'm saying it's like I had
to like go through
so many things to make it you know I had
to go through you know
um
uh you know shifting into you know going
over to a new label um
um you know um just losing friends uh
you know physical altercations all kind
of things you know all kind of drama you
know really like uh built up into this
so uh
that's why it's kind of like it's kind
of like my baby I feel like I've been
carrying this [ __ ] for like nine
months and that's finally about to drop
so it's crazy it's been a lot put into
this record man
um I hate when people be like oh yeah
this is the most personal record
all my records personal you know what
I'm saying like I'm a person that rap
about himself so every record gonna be
you know kind of personal you know it's
just all about how you decode it and dig
into it but uh you know um
after you know the Grammy thing
um and all of that in the course of that
man you know it was a lot of hurt a lot
of pain you know these past like 16
months you know but I'm glad that I was
able to you know culminate that into the
record though for sure yeah I mean
obviously the Grammy nomination was a
big look you should have won definitely
weird they know that I think you know I
love uh they know that you know I think
I think it was kind of like when
Leonardo DiCaprio won that one uh Oscar
for the bear movie but I did my saluting
to NAS it was like okay cool right but I
think I think me and you talked about it
before I was like dude I got a feeling
like Naz has never won a Grammy I got a
feeling they're gonna like this is like
kind of like if we're gonna give a
Grammy to NAS it's got to be now yeah
could nobody else beat me in the end I
wouldn't right but you had the album of
the year you had the album of the Year
by far
um totally so what was it like did you
expect to win or were you kind of like
like expecting like I guess what
happened
just always expect to make you know one
of the best albums of the year you know
I didn't expect to get nominated for
Grammy at all you know if that
especially independent album that was
icing on the cake I'm the first person
to do that by the way you know what I'm
saying but um
I you know I didn't expect I wasn't I
can't say I expected that no but um at
the same time I I think that I'm one of
the you know best rappers that like you
know making a full body of work every
time I release it you know because
everybody don't need to be like an album
artist some people just need to just
drop a couple singles you know I mean
throughout the year you know but I don't
think everybody will you know put the
time to you know bring that whole LP
across in the in the correct fashion you
know and you know a couple people did it
this year but uh for the most part you
know in the streaming era rap where we
at you know [ __ ] this just better for
these [ __ ] just come with a
couple of good songs a year and or
overly flood the marketplace that too
you know I mean or overly flooded you
know I I'm not going I'm not a hot I'm
not a a a a a a high volume shooter so
I'm not gonna get you I ain't gonna give
you more than one project in a year
though yeah it's just saying me you know
what I mean because I just want
everything that I do to be special you
can call it old school you can call it
whatever but uh you know I'd rather just
put all my energy you know from the year
and something great you know and then
and and that just adds to my collections
you know I mean I feel like you know I
got a pinata bandana I feel like the
bandana Alfredo back-to-back years was
like a crazy
I don't I mean I know Lambo tweeted it
but like to have two albums like that in
less than a year is [ __ ] insane yeah
it was insane but with that being said
um you did say recently you were like yo
when I drop like it's like I drop
Classics like yeah when you drop like
it's crazy how much merch you guys
dropped off of Alfredo how much that I
mean the tour happened
[ __ ] yeah a year and a half I mean I
don't even know because you had to tour
both albums right it's it and I to be
honest I haven't even really you know
the pandemic really limited me from
touring Alfredo the way I wanted to so I
haven't really uh I mean I tour when I
do the songs but you know to have like I
didn't really get to do an official
Alfredo tour really because of the
pandemic stuff but once touring rev back
up I was right back out there
uh you know all over the country all
over the world and that's what it is
with me I feel like uh everything has to
be set up you know from you know to
satisfy my core fan base so that I can
tour you know I mean uh I don't really
look at
and I know rapper that I really look at
that I'll be like oh man I'm trying to
like model my career after them right
not no more definitely not know like
newer rapper you know I mean like I look
at you know and take tidbits here and
there from you know to to adapt to you
know what's going on but of course for
the most part you know I'd be trying to
look at my myself like you know like I
don't know like Jerry Garcia or
something like that I went my dad and
his friends they went to like a Grateful
Dead show when I was little and it was
like a million people out there and
these [ __ ] was like 60 years old up
there and I'm like damn like okay
they can do music from their 20s until
their 60s
I gotta you know that that's that's
longevity right there why can't a rapper
do that why you got to fall off yeah I'm
saying like you know I feel like you
just gotta Just Master the art of not
falling off longevity man yeah some
people got to be like that and something
like says some people got to be high
volume Shooters and you know work it
worked for you know a few people and but
it worked for like NBA young boy he
could put out album every month Jesus
this guy he put out album every week he
I think they said he's put out like 87
songs this year and shout out to him
because his fans eat it up that's what
I'm saying like you know he's an example
of a great high volume shooter you know
what I'm saying he's like AI I mean [ __ ]
that works for him yeah definitely works
man 100 man yeah I'm more like Magic
Johnson or something like that take a
look you know I want to bring it all
together all the pieces they're like
Giannis you stay down it pays off got
your brings got your MVP Trophies
definitely I'm about to get another one
you're about to get another one
um
so obviously with triple S man there was
uh a couple of records that didn't end
up making this album one in which that
um
I mean there were some video photos of
you in the studio with Pharrell and I
know that that was one of the records
that
was close to making the album
um I'm sure one day it'll leak or not
leak I don't know a lot of people
probably have the song but um
great record you know it was a cool
record right what ended up happening why
why didn't the Pharrell record end up
making the project uh I mean I think
that came down to you know
uh for real business you know that ain't
that any it definitely had nothing to do
with me right you know I mean that that
that's something from his team you know
you have to talk to him about that what
up y'all we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our new sponsors our
family at hardean Las Vegas you see what
it is you see what it is welcome to the
family heart Dean man we're so excited
I've been going to Harding for so many
years for people who don't know Hardin
is that premium cannabis dispensary the
number one award-winning dispensary in
Las Vegas I'm talking the biggest and
best selection of cannabis product and
of course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to hardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n Las vegas.com and don't
forget when you go to Vegas you go to
Jardin tell them I sent you and then
only might throw a little extra little
eighth in the bag or something leave a
little discount the bootleg discount you
know what I'm saying get them Backwoods
too they give me a Packwood the other
day geez I'm still recovering from that
[ __ ] blew my whole [ __ ] face off in
the best way Harding Las Vegas all right
shout out to them let's get back to the
interview you and Ross have had a pretty
crazy run in terms of getting on records
together obviously he's on the new album
as well uh he was on Alfredo he's on ice
cream
initially you guys didn't have the
greatest relationship if we'd go back to
like the 600 Ben's days
you guys didn't have any relationship
but at the time there was you know the
the the CTE you were kind of like I
would say that like you didn't have a
relationship but I think maybe like fan
perspective wise it might not have been
the craziest based on just the OG Jeezy
Ross days when you were on CTE but like
talk about because you and Ross
obviously have like super locked in like
what are some things I know he's one of
the few guys you really respect
um what are some things that like
you guys have you know uh been working
on uh and what are some things you've
just learned from them and like talk
about just that chemistry because you
guys are I mean [ __ ] three for three
four for four yeah we do we do some good
records together and I uh I appreciate
Ross you know we got things being hurt
um you know I just feel like uh you know
in his Lane he just you know one of the
coldest he wanted to goats so uh
you know I I always enjoy doing a record
with them and you know we always come
out with magic but um you know I mean
what can't you learn from Rick Ross I
mean he like a motivational speaker you
get up and tweet something you know
motivational every day so you know and
um
from every everything he do you know
from the you know the small things from
the cross selection you know I mean you
know you got to admire that about him so
you know and like I said he wanted the
best to ever you know get on the mic and
I think that I think his I think Ross
really underrated on the mic really I
always say
like I have him in my like top 10 to 15
of all time range and I think most
people would like look at me crazy I
don't really know no orders but but he's
like you're up there I think like one of
the greatest flows ever he's got a
classic album chapter one Don's a
classic definitely uh and he's
probably got top two or three best ear
for Beats ever that too yeah definitely
and like if you just think about like
just like Legacy wise like MMG man [ __ ]
like that 2010 2011 2012 those self-made
projects helping put Meek on can't erase
that I mean I got Rick Ross on my own
just so I can get that Maybach Music on
there some kind of way so if that came
with a verse that just came with a verse
yeah that's shout out to shout out to
Ross yeah I mean I think uh Ross man
yeah he's fired and I feel like you guys
you guys trade bars on records together
it just sounds like damn like I I know
we always talk about like you're doing
joint albums obviously you've done joint
albums with producers but like
um would you do a joint album with
someone like Ross yeah I definitely
would definitely yeah it's like it's
like very few guys on the it's a short
list of guys that I would do that with
but yeah Ross definitely one of those
guys that I would Pusha T yeah I would
yeah I would make that I would if we
could man look if we can make it I'm
down to do whatever you know I mean as
long as the politics and business and
[ __ ] don't get in the way that's what I
hate about this rap [ __ ] that's what
made me be like you know what [ __ ] it I
just that that's that's the type of [ __ ]
that made me want to do an album with no
features that's type [ __ ] that made me
just want to just go in there and rap
and just do my own thing because I don't
be liking the when the business and [ __ ]
because you might talk to the artist or
the producer like face to face and
everything's all good and then you know
I mean like I said most of this [ __ ] on
this album was organic man like when you
gotta like
you know when I got to go you got to go
through so many layers of people to like
[ __ ] with the artists and don't even it
ain't even worth it man you know that
[ __ ] is it take the feel from the record
to me it's like [ __ ] it I don't even
really want to do it yeah yeah I can't
text you from like [ __ ] whack yeah no
it's like what's the point [ __ ] like
but uh you know it is what it is man you
know you know sometimes you got to do
things to that's suitable for business
yeah one of the craziest records I heard
on this album is the DJ Paul record is
[ __ ] crazy yeah now that was one of
the that was probably the one of the
most organ the most I remember how
excited you were when you first did it I
mean that's one of my heroes you know
what I'm saying like I've been listening
Three Six Mafia since I was a child so
it was just like
you know to get actually in the studio
with them speaking of underrated
underrated producers because I worked
with Juicy J before right you know what
I'm saying but like we didn't actually I
didn't I wasn't able to actually get in
the studio right right you know what I'm
saying but like doing this thing with
Paul was amazing it was like having one
of your cousins at a cookout just
chilling chopping game you know I mean
and we just did a couple records and
it became like one of the anchors of the
album I think yeah his production is so
slept on man so slept on he still Paul
got that heat a lot of [ __ ]
copying Paul to be honest you know what
I'm saying Paul got that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you know try to replicate
but they can't you know hundred percent
a hundred percent man do you did you
feel any sort of pressure to do like a
more like
single friendly records since this is
like your major label debut not at all
not at all
um
I knew uh what came with this [ __ ] when
I you know
um started uh working with a major I
knew that uh
you know you had to put you know um
maybe radio records up on the board I
don't know I just made records and if
you know I gave it to him and if
whatever the team picked the records
right I just made the best I just made
the best records that I like you know I
mean I kind of just let loose and just
um just try to be as comfortable as
possible
um and just you know just show that I've
been you know the one of the most
versatile artists in the game period and
that was easy you know I don't think
that uh
I set out to like make a whole bunch of
like singles though nah I never did that
so especially when I'm making an album
you know I feel like uh people that do
that I feel like you're just like
turning in a playlist and not a album a
cohesive body or what I was trying to
make an album I wasn't trying to like oh
let me make six singles and like I don't
I ain't like bro I ain't never been on
the radio so I would uh I never played
that game you know so like now that they
you know playing the records on the
radio yeah you got a record like too
much that you know it's top three out of
that uh radio that's crazy to hear that
yeah I mean because I you know that I
never been in that position I tell you
this all the time but like you are truly
like an anomaly in terms of like
Instagram you're like the Andrew Tata
hip-hop in terms of just them trying to
cancel you on social media I'm not
saying like the things you'd be saying
like bro you get a new Instagram I feel
like every four weeks there's a new page
they delete your [ __ ] I don't even need
it I'm just outselling there I don't
even need it it's just crazy that you
don't even have like a like a Instagram
page to promote your music and you're
still out streaming everybody you still
have the anticipation and I can do a
tour and you're selling out your whole
tour yeah with no pay this [ __ ]
got holes it's like you just have
Twitter [ __ ] just [ __ ] just be empty
baby with that being said since they
keep deleting your pages have you
thought about posting less naked
crackheads on your story no no that's
what I do I like I like the you know
crackhead culture you know I mean it's
great I love cracker culture too those
are the people that I come from those
are my people yeah you know what I mean
so now I'll be posting them I'll be
digging them up one time I posted this
dude
he's with this crackhead there's a black
dude some dude with dreads or something
like a little you know all these [ __ ]
got dreads now but uh I don't know I
don't know maybe that was Reverse Racism
on myself but I don't know
this [ __ ] uh was doing something with
some white lady or something I don't
know but it was funny to me so I posted
it and he seen me in the street and he
was like yo that's my lady you can't be
posting me I was like [ __ ] if you don't
get the [ __ ] wait the crackhead saw you
yeah I think he was a crackhead I was at
like Smashburger or something eating a
hamburger [ __ ] was like yo man you
posted me and my girl I was like man I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't I don't really
care you know you got the good crack
post all that the [ __ ] post but it's the
thing though man I post jokes about
myself too so just because I joke on you
know I mean I don't like you people no
you're you you're very good at
self-deprecating humor yeah they be
taking that [ __ ] too seriously like
you'll repost somebody who like posts
like one of the like 11 people who
people say you look like like Don
Cheadle by the way Shadow's a guy from
Yahoo who like called Don Cheadle he
definitely called Don Cheadle out Don
Cheadle look I talked to Don Cheadle he
said gonna kick that dude in the dick
he said he said ain't my favorite rapper
Freddie Gibbs I'm not sure if he was in
on the joke or not Don ain't like that
he was like he was like what he said I
was gonna kick him in the dick you know
what I'm saying but he was like you know
what I kept my cool cause I'm working on
the movie and I don't want to hit nobody
yeah no it's it's but is it frustrating
to not have an like I mean you have an
IG
now you do I got a couple ones
um but like your official page you don't
have you don't have an official page
anymore like no because I think you got
it back for a little bit though right I
did when I signed Warner they tried to
make this little Freddie Gibbs official
I got that [ __ ] took too so if you get
it back do you think we could just only
let Lambo post on it so they don't take
it down what's the fun in it then you
have the other one for all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't I mean I guess I mean it's been
I guess as we've seen it it's proven
that I don't [ __ ] mean you don't need
it this is true I don't even [ __ ]
need it at this point [ __ ] like what is
it what the [ __ ] is uh Zuckerberg and
metal gonna the [ __ ] gonna do to me this
is true they can't stop the music the
[ __ ] coming out and if they stop me I'll
just make another one my fans be making
my Instagram page you know that I didn't
know that they'd be making them for me
they'd be like let's go to get shut down
oh I got a new one for you right here
here's the password here's the email
I'll be like all right thanks
I'll be making them shits for a [ __ ] so
I'll be like do you remember like the
specific thing that uh got your official
page taken down what was I feel like
yeah a year and a half ago yeah it was a
video of this uh African dude in an
African village
and like this girl or titties had
stretched out and his eyes stretched out
and the nipple in the eyeball met and
then it was like no more page for
Freddie Gibbs it was a wrap [ __ ] yeah it
was like nah I'm Freddy you can't be
doing that [ __ ] man you know what I'm
saying like
it ain't looking good for you and I was
like damn that's [ __ ] up you know what
I'm saying but uh
you know I was kind of mad at first but
I ain't really tripping like you're
popping up with a new page every year
yeah I probably I'll just be on there to
look at girls anyway yeah that's what I
really look at it for I don't care about
promotional music it's a nice comedic
outlet for you though yeah it is cool
that's what I liked about it I invented
that [ __ ] on the story not everybody's
doing that [ __ ] on stories on you know
but I created that line you know I feel
like you could do like a like a variety
show like a Ridiculousness but like the
Freddie Gibbs version yeah definitely we
working on that we got that in the works
right now it's crazy you say that oh got
that in the work man you know what I'm
saying that's we gotta you know
this rap [ __ ] only lasts forever I can't
be the best rapper forever you know what
I'm saying well first of all I'd like to
point out that you've been amazing in
every acting role your movie is
incredible
um you killed it and then the uh the NBC
the peacock show you're [ __ ]
hilarious and I have I have people
hitting me up I've never watched power
um but I have people who like have sent
me you on Power and been like yo is he
really cockeyed yeah I mean no I'm not
no but I'd be like I'd be like no but
he's like boys
but that was a good makeup shout out to
power shout out to Joe sakur and 50 Cent
and everybody over there my boy Chris
Laughlin shout out to them that was that
was cool the thing to do I love acting I
damn love acting more just as much as I
like rapping well like talk to me about
the acting thing is it like something
that is a little is it like a new
challenge for you there's a few more
natural stuff I mean you know it's
definitely a new challenge
um uh you know working with you know
different people different producers and
directors you know they want to see
different things so uh you know I
definitely go into every job to uh you
know a new mentality and a fresh
mentality a learning mentality like you
know trying to soak things up from like
you know other uh well-seasoned actors
and things of that nature you know I
don't walk on the [ __ ] movie
Set like I'm some rapper and y'all gotta
do all this [ __ ] for me you know I'll go
on there and do my job with humility and
and maintain my uh what I'm supposed to
do was the doing the whole movie uh like
because obviously doing like smaller
roles on shows probably not as like
taxing mentally and physically like I
don't want that [ __ ] no more like so if
you got a little roll don't even give me
that [ __ ] no more don't even call me I
don't even call Lambo don't call Dan
don't call my agent I don't even want it
like because like you do the movie you
have like a you know yeah like you end
up having a love interest in a random
white lady at a hardware store yeah it
looks like my Aunt shout out to her ah
man come on man
you don't think she could be my aunt
that [ __ ] was amazing it was great I'm
just saying like it's a whole nother
level of like commitment I remember when
you were out of town was it three four
weeks that it took you to shoot the
movie how long was that oh yeah about
yeah about four weeks yeah you know what
I'm saying like you know but I I like
the way we did that and then we went
straight to cans with that so it's like
that that alone right there on my first
like movie it made me like all right I'm
just gonna attack this film [ __ ] like I
attacked the rap [ __ ] I'm not about to
take no for an answer I ain't about to
just play some [ __ ] role I don't want
to do you know I mean I ain't doing that
you know what I mean but at the same
time when I do get a good role like I
said I'm gonna approach it with humility
but it's just certain things that you
know that I envisioned for myself you
know I mean um you know in the game and
if I can't
get those things by asking I'm just
going to take it yeah that's it that's
beautiful uh you mentioned this album
being like one of the hardest things I
mean obviously publicly went through a
lot of [ __ ] in terms of just like
definitely beefs
oh I mean listen man
um did you ever feel like
in the last like year and a half or so
like what would you say like was like
the lowest point for you in terms of
just like
because there was a lot of [ __ ] you know
like like again I feel like there was a
point in time where you were kind of off
Twitter off Instagram and people are
saying what they're saying they're right
kind of coming up with their own
conclusions on what may or may not have
happened in your life and was that like
tough to get through
um no I wouldn't I mean I mean yeah I
wouldn't say you can't really control
your own narrative or you weren't you
know the the public narrative was kind
of out there with a lot of these
situations you were in yeah I think that
um
I think that uh um
she is the thing with me
you know
I'm like the easiest
probably easiest biggest person in like
rap to like have a problem with you know
what I'm saying I'm like a a easy Target
because I'm not affiliated with none of
these like big guys I'm not affiliated
with Jay-Z I ain't affiliated with Dr
Dre you're on Freddie Gibbs Island there
you go I'm on an island by myself so
like when a rapper feel like he needs
some type of like adversary or some [ __ ]
like that like I'm like oh [ __ ] it it's
easy to go with me because it ain't no
they feel they feel like
it ain't no repercussions behind it you
know what I'm saying until they you know
come bark up the wrong tree and then you
know they then they uh a month later
they'd be
trying to squash it so it's just like
you know
I don't really you know if I gave a [ __ ]
about like a public opinion or how
[ __ ] felt about me then I wouldn't
even be where I'm at because they've
been told me that I couldn't rap that I
was trash that I shouldn't do this and
do all of that so I I never cared about
that
um you know and in those couple of
situations where it was off
damn y'all rude [ __ ]
in those couple situations
where I had a
altercations or whatnot you know like
[ __ ] I was you know eating food with my
girl you know and um the [ __ ] I
had altercations with I never looked at
them as like no type of hell of a [ __ ]
or was like moved by them in no kind of
way you know and they know that they
know who I am they know what I do so you
know what they do they got to bring 10
people 30 people 20 people I have a
multiple gods amount of people to try to
fight
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture all my guys
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you two hundred dollars on top of
that to gamble with for free if you put
in a thousand dollars they're gonna
match that deposit with a free thousand
dollars for you to gamble with right now
so what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
let's get this money let's watch some
[ __ ] football and let's get paid with
my bookie let me ask you this because
you obviously have a serious amount of
jewelry
um
you know the the rabbit pendant is
insane but I do feel like you know when
you see something like you know you told
me that the pnb rock [ __ ] kind of hits
you man like we've been seeing a lot of
artists lose their life over jewelry and
[ __ ] like are you a lot more you know
hesitant to move around with all your
[ __ ] on are you a lot more alert you're
always alert you know but in terms of
just like
you know I mean listen you live in L.A
it's a time and a place for all of that
stuff I think you know I mean um I don't
think you know
you don't gotta wear all your [ __ ] I
think any [ __ ] that wear all his [ __ ]
when you go outside is kind of like damn
you ain't damn okay let's see what I'm
saying like so I just feel like
um
I feel like you should be able to do
what you want man and nobody should
[ __ ] touch you dog like uh but I
don't think that's reality I know it's
not reality I'm just saying you know I
mean like uh and I like a lot of people
like everybody's a a a analyst when it
comes to these type of situations like
he shouldn't have did this he shouldn't
have did that he wouldn't bothering
nobody man I agree he wasn't bothering
nobody I don't give a [ __ ] where he was
at nobody should have [ __ ] with him I
agree and that's the problem with y'all
[ __ ] you know I'm saying like [ __ ]
think oh like [ __ ] I should be able to
do whatever the [ __ ] I want to wear I
know that ain't reality I know it's not
so I just protect what I got you know I
mean and it is what it is you know what
I'm saying like but you look at this
[ __ ] though
like you asked me about
um oh that I uh think about all like you
know what [ __ ] were saying and
all of this [ __ ] during during my
situation so you look at my situation
like [ __ ] like 30 [ __ ] came to
a restaurant I was eating it and I what
if I would have died yeah
Freddie Gibbs oh man he was great he was
that what academics be saying I was a
great rapper on his post
but now since you know I'm saying since
[ __ ] tried to jump me oh man he got
jumped it's a different thing now what
if pnb rock you know what I'm saying
what you know
yeah
exactly exactly even worse and even
worse what if he would have just gave it
up
gave it up people have been like yeah
what if you would have gave it up and
lived it's a lose lose for a [ __ ] so
what the [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] want from us
yeah
that's real I would have gave it up
y'all y'all would have clowned me my
career y'all oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] mm-hmm
but if I fight for mine and die
oh man you shouldn't even been there man
suck my dick all these fans all these
people I don't give a [ __ ] about none of
that dog at the end of the day yeah you
know what I mean like bro I should be
able to do what the [ __ ] I want to do
[ __ ] y'all
[ __ ] I work hard for mine
you know what I'm saying and hey
try it it is what it is man you know you
just gotta just pray every day and just
move correctly dog but that man
shouldn't he shouldn't have been
bothered he wasn't bothering nobody dog
you know what I'm saying he was having a
[ __ ] meal he just got the end of the
[ __ ] day dog yeah having a meal with
his girl
um
then the reason that [ __ ] touched me
like that because that could have been
me then whatever [ __ ] would have said
yeah
that shit's crazy then what
I just think we're just like
like growing up like I feel like when
Tupac and Biggie died it was such a big
deal because we weren't used to to
losing people but I feel like nowadays
it's like it happened so often that it's
like [ __ ] like
when like like rapping might be the most
dangerous job when people say that like
per capita [ __ ] is really
losing their life at a high level it
could be man that's why you got to use
this [ __ ] as a springboard to get you
somewhere else man yeah you know what
I'm saying because like [ __ ] just being
identified as a rapper like if a bunch
of [ __ ] here who he's a rapper he's a
rap he do what oh [ __ ] that already
automatically put eyes on you
[ __ ] see what they they want to
test your nuts they want to see if you
can protect what you got they want to
see if you could fight they want to see
if you about that [ __ ] you rhyming hmm
you know what I mean so you
automatically you know the [ __ ]
microscope from [ __ ] from other
[ __ ] uh punk ass rappers from
[ __ ] police you know what I mean so
you know it's you know it's it's a
difficult it's definitely a difficult
occupation to be and uh I mean you've
always played with the idea of retiring
like I've heard you say multiple times
this is my last album yeah I feel like
that every time I do an album
because like so many opportunities open
up for me when I do each album you know
I mean like I did Alfredo so many like
the film opportunities start opening up
for me you know what I mean you know I
mean dude you're doing stand-up like
exactly in Austin comedy stand-up comedy
distant rappers on stand-up comedy you
know you ever been disc in a stand-up
routine like [ __ ]
I don't even got a rap about you listen
it's really rough to go like like I'll
just say this like and this is not to
anyone in particular but like if there
was a single person I wouldn't want to
like get into some internet [ __ ] with it
be you because oh yeah you're [ __ ]
because I'm a turtle you're the funniest
rapper because I'm gonna turn it into
comedy bed I'm gonna turn everything
into so funny man because it's all jokes
to me you know what I'm saying like you
know we can laugh about all of this [ __ ]
the whole time you know what I'm saying
to you you know try to get physical but
other than that like you know you know
like [ __ ] tried to play with me
and I'll just make their ass and I turn
their ass into memes as academics you
know what I'm saying like and like I
said I don't even know him like that
either I probably met him like once or
twice but you know it seem like he got
everything in world to say about me and
that's cool they've been a he's been a
big promotional Force for me these past
two years so thank you academics I
appreciate you do you feel like there
was an important time during the
academics thing maybe you're putting a
little too much energy into act not at
all I just did the other day on Flex
what you mean because I never ain't
never too much energy ain't no ain't no
ain't never too much energy into a [ __ ]
that talk about your girl your family
ain't never too much yeah it ain't never
too much energy [ __ ] You're Gonna Get
You Gonna Get these [ __ ]
bullets whenever I shoot them out
figuratively of course yeah yeah I like
that yeah
I feel like I could sit down and talk to
the [ __ ] he ain't no like hell of a
[ __ ] he ain't like no [ __ ] you got to
be afraid of no no no so we could
probably have a conversation you know I
mean I I don't need to hurt him you know
I mean I don't need to like hit him or
no [ __ ] like that I don't I don't feel
that way because I don't feel that he's
any type of threat he's just a [ __ ]
that's posting about me on the [ __ ]
internet what the [ __ ] can you do to me
right I don't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah so I felt like if he was in the
room we could even talk and I'd be like
you wrong you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna say all that [ __ ]
to your face and then I'm gonna like
this here's why and you can say how you
feel about me and here's why and that's
that and if you feel away about it after
keep it moving or fight or excuse me
yeah man we still be cool after that
it's cool who all uh production wise do
we have on Triple S obviously uh DJ Paul
Alchemist obviously Alchemist Mad Lib
that's crazy I got both of them on there
DJ Parts
um
damn Yeah Boy Wonder for show we got
some other [ __ ] that we did that didn't
we just we did so many records we just I
just couldn't fit them all but we gonna
do some more [ __ ] uh who else uh
produced on this album
man damn
why is my mind going blank right now but
you know shout out to everybody that
produced on the album man I'm tripping
right now I think I smoked the wrong
thing but
you you get the idea yeah I mean have an
alchemist and Mad Libs important though
yeah yeah both of them on the major come
on man definitely you know what I'm
saying so important to your career both
of those guys
oh I'm sorry kaytranada kaytranada
um
who else
oh I gotta think about it man God damn
man you caught me off guard let me look
at my phone have you guys already uh
kicked the idea around to doing Alfredo
too
oh
what's funny you say that but I just
told you that every time I do an album I
feel like it's so it's I might not do
another one I got a lot of stuff to do
like man bro this whole process
recording the album I barely got to see
my kids a lot you know I mean touring
like man I'm ready I'm really ready to
just chill dog I don't know if I can go
through the process or recording the
album no more really I don't know if I
can after this I mean I feel like this
probably is this again like you said
it's one of my best albums you know I
mean and I feel and like I said I feel
like that every time I do one so I'm
like damn man
you know I'll be like have a topic you
listen you did two with Mad Lib I feel
like it's only right you do two with
Alchemist
I totally agree with you yeah but
you know I don't know man I just don't
know if I want to do another album right
now do you feel like you've kind of also
helped like kick off the trend of doing
like the fool because I feel like I see
people doing like like I feel like you
know the whole locking in with a
producer yeah definitely I think that I
do that the best you know I mean out of
uh anybody because pinata was what 2014
right right right I think I do that the
best I think uh Rock Marciano just did
that with Alchemist and that was tight
great album yeah that was tight great
album shout out to rock Marcy that was
tight I was supposed to do something
with rock with timing and everything
easy awesome I like him yeah definitely
I love Rockmart he's incredible
um
cease I mean if they have you know maybe
we can make that happen I love
Alchemists that's like my brother so we
flirt with the idea all the time you
know what I'm saying and if I was to
make another if I was to do another
album it would be that one yeah you know
what I mean so if there is another album
after Triple S Alfredo too yeah maybe
maybe I don't know man I don't want to
record right now but I just want to go
get a boat that's fair you know what I'm
saying go go I want to chill work on
this variety show that you just thought
yeah I got so I got the variety show I
got a couple films I got like three
movies I just signed on to do like it
was like for real like so I'm like I
really I don't know if I got I really
don't know you might have time I might
not have time to do another album right
now dog for like five years like for
real I got so much stuff going up man my
kids getting bigger dog you know what
I'm saying they like it's you know they
they need me to be around a lot right
now for sure you know I kind of gotta
after I do all of this triple that stuff
you know I kind of gotta like sit down
for a little bit sit down and go into
dad mode for a minute because you know I
deprived them of lot of time the past
two years because I had to like
get where I wanted to be career-wise so
that I can you know continue to provide
for them for life you know people always
talk about how like comedians at least
right they'll go on Joe Rogan and like
changes their their career trajectory
when you went on Joe Rogan you've been
on twice yeah shout out to Brian Moses
shout out to Moses I gotta get with
Moses today matter of fact
did you notice like uh like just this
any sort of like spike in listenership
or like
because you went on the first time I
actually went to Austin with you yeah
uh I think Joe Rogan is like he like the
king of white people man so it's
definitely somewhere
he's up there so my white people
definitely you know start rocking with
me he might be just the king of like
everything males yeah you like male
testosterone energy like you know Joe
Joe is my guy man so uh you know um
shout out to him and just allowing me to
come on the show you know um and I'm
about to go back on there again matter
of fact I missed jokes I'm supposed to
go to the fight with Joe but I couldn't
I couldn't make it because I'm doing all
this album stuff but uh you know Joe's
like he's you know a comedic genius you
know great podcast genius did that first
episode you guys did was four like four
hours long I could sit with Joe all day
saying the way I can sit with you yeah
you know I mean I want to take you on
there with me you want to go in there
please you should go on there with me
man you should go in there with me and
Brian Moses I'm down that would be
amazing you know what I'm saying I think
that we could do a five hour show you
know how many times on this podcast I've
told the story story about the day that
we met Joe Rogan and I shrooms with you
and Fit Mommy in Austin oh yeah and I
was tripping [ __ ] hard on Sixth damn
I remember that day that was like one of
the worst that was like I was [ __ ] up
bro that was a crazy and your girl kept
[ __ ] with me making wild ass [ __ ]
faces and she's still here then I was
alone she had a little bit of hair down
here it was real short yeah she had like
the yeah yeah she's like a little pixie
cut a little something yeah something
like that that's before the ball ball
but you also went on Joe [ __ ] like right
after like they tried to cancel him and
I love how you kind of yeah yeah cause
that's my friend yeah you know what I'm
saying and he he [ __ ] up he made a
mistake yeah it is what it is I don't
think that he like you know I didn't
think that he like hated black people or
[ __ ] like that you know what I'm saying
because a lot of people say that [ __ ]
with Force I don't think he was saying
that [ __ ] would force you know said like
and you know Dave Chappelle kick it with
the [ __ ] so how bad could he be right I
think two comedians I think like if you
look at like some comedy right like
comedians I feel like they come from a
perspective of like nothing's off limits
nothing that's why I love Dave Chappelle
because he don't give a [ __ ] like if you
watch a Louis CK special he's he's
joking about the wildest [ __ ] the
wildest [ __ ] I love Louis CK too you
know I'm saying shout out to Louis CK
shout out to Jeff Ross all my homies in
that whole comedic world man you know
could you see yourself doing like a
little like like a little stand-up run
oh hell yeah definitely man I'm about to
shout out to Chris red I think that me
and Chris red about to put something
together for sure but uh man all my
homies in comedy rest in peace Jack
night man
um shout out to Sam J I just talked to
Sam it's crazy I just talked to Sam
before I came in you know I feel like
they really you know you know Brian
Moses really
um catapult to me in that world man we
got to get him some new Jordans
I want to take them shoe shots take them
all take them shopping periods
I got you man yeah he'll be tying the
[ __ ] like he about to go
dunking he got those Team Jordans for
sure I'm getting my [ __ ] be out
here wearing a pair of Eddie Jones
maybe having the six rings elevens is
like just tied tight tied all the way to
the top to the top three a little bit of
God damn shoe bed but yeah he but Moses
put me in that world man you know I
ain't look back you know I mean
um I shot a movie with the Lucas
Brothers
shout out to them I forgot I forgot we
even did that wow you know what I'm
saying so uh you know that was like a
short film that we did that was amazing
um it's just it's so many things um
media wise
so many ways that I want to you know
express myself you know I just feel like
I don't know like you know rappers
coming trying to start and become
secondary to those you know because it's
like like I said it's a you know I'm
still learning myself I'm still growing
you know I mean um the rap is such a
huge part of my life you know I mean
I've been doing this [ __ ] since I was 20
years old and now I'm 40. so it's just
like but if you would have told me
at 20 years old
um that I was uh gonna have to wait
this long to have you know to be
to to get the respect that I want I
probably would have told you that I I
quit I probably would have been like
[ __ ] that I ain't doing that you know
what I'm saying but uh
I worked at it I persevered man and took
time you know what I'm saying
um lots of lots of areas of your career
too and I never peaked I never peaked
out you know what I'm saying and I don't
even think about the peak right now I
just feel like a consistency and um you
know just being dedicated to the craft
man dedicated to being a rapper you know
what I'm saying first and not just a
uh uh somebody trying to catch a wave
you know I mean or catch a record like
you know I never cared about that you
know as long as people always said off
Freddy gives one of the best rappers
I saw that really mattered to me you
know I'm saying like you know when you
gave me that respect you know I ain't
want to fizzle out I ain't wanna you
know cause
a lot of guys come in the game and they
have
big records early you know and you know
they probably not around right now you
know I mean or probably can't get
nothing going right now they probably
put their record out and they're just
like you know what I'm saying and this
one and these guys I got
Platinum hits you know what I'm saying
I've been to like the year that you made
the freshman cover was that 2010 2010
yeah so the 2010 freshman cover and in
2000 20 you get nominated for best rap
album 2021 is when the Grammys were
right yeah that's like 11 years later
right my freshman year freshman cover
it's probably only like three guys left
on that that you want to hear because
it's you with nipples on that cover me
nip yeah
pill Pew shout out to Pale Man you know
I've kind of discovered both of y'all
together low-key where's
who else is under the cover um J Cole
Cole was on that guy God damn that was a
crazy cover oh oh OJ the juice man six
rings on like a basketball player six
rings on like a bat that was his
freestyle you know how I remember it
because you were were you a part of that
because there was only two lines of it
don't like a basketball player what a
six rings on like a basketball player I
was like what the [ __ ] about up here
what are we doing yeah I'm up here
rapping my ass off
six weeks old like a basketball player
hey y'all like oh my God I was like oh I
was like [ __ ]
I said what am I that's it I said I
don't know if I'm gonna be in this rap
game long man like I said it's you know
what I'm saying and I love I love
overlay the juice man you know Classic
record shout out to OJ that was a
classic freshman freestyle that he did
right there too that was amazing
memorable you remember you never
remember here I don't remember my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] was been weak I remember his
though for sure
that let me know right there like it
stood out and sometimes you got to do
things that stand out more than others
and that that's what that that's what
that day taught me I didn't condemn his
freestyle I was just like huh you know I
mean what am I doing but it was God
teaching me a lesson like look [ __ ]
this like you yeah you think you can rap
you got a lot of words you put together
but that [ __ ] right there had
Showmanship and you don't have that yet
that's that's that's fair yeah I mean we
had a freestyle go viral this dude named
Haiti baby I don't know if you saw it he
was like uh
he was like hi hi it was crazy it went
viral Rihanna posted it everybody posted
it and it was when I walked like when I
was sitting next to the guy I was like
this is like the worst [ __ ] I've ever is
that that [ __ ] that you was with uh
what me and head you went head yeah
shout out these are here man good guy
man salute to my brother DJ hand we
gotta stop the interview tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks well first of
all let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg kept sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too it's an odd sock right
there that's awesome basic you know what
I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd Socks you
should too they got the crazy licenses
we're talking about Nickelodeon shout
out to Patrick [ __ ] Cheez-Its
Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview uh
I don't know if a lot of people know
this but you and Jeezy ran into each
into each other at an airport damn okay
if you know it see you be tough you do
interviews with your friends they bring
up [ __ ] did you tell them nothing bad
happened no you ain't bring up [ __ ] that
you tell them in confidence I didn't
know this was in confidence we edit it
out no we don't nothing bad happened it
was a positive no we don't edit [ __ ]
when I come on here well the last time
you came on we did edit a lot out well
yeah I want to go to jail uh but now but
you guys ran into each other at the
airport what happened oh yeah I seen him
at the airport
that's damn that's crazy bro it's the
first just we're all permitted [ __ ] but
uh
I see Jeezy at the airport uh with his
wife
I was with my girl and um
I seen him we shook hands and hugged and
[ __ ] was just like man salute it was
just like damn it was like a relief for
like both of us I feel like you know it
was like a hug or we exchanged numbers
and we both got on a plane and that was
it that's beautiful thing that it was it
was one of the most beautiful things
ever because I think you could
officially put that behind you right
I've been put it behind me but I had to
like you know like really I had to see
him I had to like really be in to direct
really officially be at peace with
correct yeah yeah yeah yeah and it would
and then when you look back man that
wasn't really nothing man I looked that
was [ __ ] a you know music
disagreement you know I mean like I
didn't really have none you know um
against Jeezy I looked up to Jeezy you
know I mean cheesy one of my favorite
rappers you know I mean I learned a lot
from him I learned to you know really
how to carry myself in this rap game by
being around him so
um you know I think that that was just a
misunderstanding miscommunication
um it ain't like all of this other [ __ ]
with these other little [ __ ] [ __ ] when
I see them slap the [ __ ] out of them you
know what I'm saying but
with that even you know it'll be times
where we'll be in the same places
all the time it's the rap game of course
of course there was nothing violent
happen or no [ __ ] like that or or nobody
was you know
disrespecting each other too bad you
know what I mean like you know we said
things but like for the most part man we
both men and I think that we was just
both trying to just get our points
across and we just just communicated it
badly and uh you know I take the blame
for that because I uh you know
I should have just like
sat tight and just let my work speak for
itself instead of like even like
speaking on it publicly at all you know
I mean I think that really what set me
off is when they asked him about me
publicly I wish he would have just
deflected that and but then I took that
[ __ ] too far and I you know I look at
that situation it's another learning
experience yeah I mean as long as you
get out learn from your fuck-ups man
yeah definitely I don't even say [ __ ]
ups just here yeah that was something
that I needed that was that was
something I needed in my career you know
what I mean like I needed that
um that opposition so to speak you know
what I'm saying almost like how Jordan
would use like the littlest thing I feel
like you're very much like that because
I know the littlest [ __ ] that might not
be directed at you but sometimes you be
taking [ __ ] personal I'll tell you yeah
I'll tell you everything that really
confuses me
but you're very good at like taking the
smallest little like just whatever
somebody says or something that happens
and you use that as like motivation
that's why I tweeted like oh the white
tweet like this my [ __ ] gonna be doing I
hate care of like man you see this you
see this [ __ ] right here and I'm just
like
feed off of it man like I'm competitive
by Nature man so it's like I feel like I
gotta have
something
to
not necessarily nobody or somebody in
particular to you know go against I
don't need that I just need some type of
motivation you know what I mean um and
maybe it it don't always got to be a
rapper that motivated me it could be
like a record executive that's tell me
that I ain't [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying or anything or a [ __ ] or [ __ ] my
baby mama telling me I can't rap all
kind of [ __ ] like anyone who told you
that huh when they mad at me but then
when the songs come out they'd be like
so crowded you got the Grammy nomination
yeah yeah
I love him too we all say [ __ ] about
each other that we shouldn't say but I
love them though at the end of the day
100
um with this project what just off the
top of your head man what's your
favorite song
uh my favorite song
probably man all these songs I like my
babies man
um
I'm gonna tell you what my least
favorite song was at first
and I didn't even um
I ain't even want to like do it you know
what I'm saying and
and it's crazy because like it's from
one of my favorite producers seven
Thomas and I ain't even like the beat he
gave me some heat he gave me a lot of a
lot of [ __ ] on this album but this one
this one in particular I was like I
don't want that one I was like that
don't sound good for me and then Lambo
kept [ __ ] [ __ ] with me yeah kept
[ __ ] bothering me I was like bro he's
like rapping this beat rapping this beat
rapping his beat I was like hey look man
you leave me the [ __ ] alone dog I'm on a
roll right here dog right I'm in the
studio with this I remember the night we
was in the studio with DJ Paul he's like
okay yeah you did that now [ __ ] with
this one and I was like no [ __ ] leave
me the [ __ ] alone
and then we was in Miami and then one
day I was just like listening to the
Bone and then I was I don't know I was
in a Groove and he played that beat and
then I forgot that's our landlord a
magician with this [ __ ] I forgot that
that was the one he was bugging me about
and then I was like he just let time go
past and I was like oh this [ __ ] hard
yeah after while my ear had to open up
and sometimes that takes time that's why
I don't like when [ __ ] like
Rush album you know what I mean because
it's always something that
somebody else to hear that you're not
hearing you know what I mean and um you
know and I hear artists all the time
like yeah this is my album my album my
album yeah my name on the [ __ ] album
but it's really all of our albums really
me my album Lambos out more vase out and
we made this [ __ ] together you know what
I'm saying like you tell me the offset
record that's the one I'm talking about
like I wasn't gonna do that record at
first and that ended up being the record
that offset wanted to get on you know
what I'm saying but at first I was just
like uh I had my doubts about it because
my ears are probably tuned into
something else and then they just like
allowed me time to tune out and then
when they brought it back around
it's gonna be a hit record you know what
I'm saying so it's like
you know I think that a lot of these
things too
um are our Collective efforts you know
making a a great body of work making a a
good album you know I mean a lot of
rappers might not have a team I got you
know I mean so they probably can't make
the album that I make because they're
just going off of their own ear and
their own emotions nobody is uh you know
directing them in any kind of way you
know I mean I can say that you can't be
the boss of the situation but I feel
like you gotta you know you need a team
you know what I'm saying Michael Jordan
needed Phil Jackson you know I mean it
got to be it got to be somebody on the
court I mean off the court looking at
[ __ ] like hold on man you don't see this
because you know eat my eyes when I when
I don't got them you know he see [ __ ]
that I can't see also your Instagram
when you don't got it that's who that
too
all those guys right shout out the level
shout out to Norway you know he made big
plays on his album you know we all it
was a real Collective effort you know
shout out to Chris Atlas and Warner you
know I mean my man Chris don't get
enough credit but uh you know I think
that we all
stuck thy strengths you know I mean I'm
the best rapper so I just stuck to that
you know um I didn't try to deviate from
that and I wanted it you know I didn't
try to like make no beats like [ __ ] I
don't make no I'm not Anderson pop right
you know what I'm saying like Anderson
Parker wrap your ass to sleep play the
drum play the drums
yeah he's a maniac I am not on his level
whatsoever you know what I'm saying but
I totally respect it that's why I had to
get him on the album but you know I just
stuck the world out you know what I know
you know what I'm saying I'm a I'm a
scorer in that regard you know and I
just you know locked in like Kobe fair
enough
um by the way free YSL free Gunner I
want to know because I know that you
guys never had a real beef I think it
was more internet comedy Fred [ __ ] but
like how crazy bro I remember when that
song came out every Club you walked into
you had to play that [ __ ] record oh
I'm still bumped that [ __ ] yeah my kids
like that [ __ ] my kids be in the
backseat I can't [ __ ] with Freddie yes
I'd be like you little [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying but uh like hey man
you know um
I don't have nothing against uh none of
them I don't even really know I mean you
you and you and Doug have a gold record
together definitely Old English
definitely I mean that's that's a big
deal yeah it's a totally big deal like
um you know then I you know I know some
people on their side when they Camp I
know Ebony shout out to ebony
um I don't have no you know Coral with
uh you know with Ghana yeah I knew you I
mean you told I mean obviously I knew
behind the scenes you had never was
never nothing you know internet jokes is
internet jokes you know I mean you make
a lot of Internet Crime Stoppers joke
was you know the Crime Stoppers joke I
mean T.I did that too you know what I'm
saying and when we joked about that and
when I did that T.I called me and we had
a conversation and I don't have no bad
words with ti either you know what I'm
saying like I said it was just to me it
was just jokes you know what I'm saying
um but you also have to understand
sometimes you're you're a rapper so when
you joke about other rappers it comes
off like more differently than if like
you know but I ain't trying to use I
ain't trying to sell records that they
they expense or anything and uh none of
that nature you know I mean I don't even
really care about you know um you know
uh you know selling as much as them or
being on a level musically I got a you
know core that I satisfy and and it's
down the third so like what Gunner was
like saying oh man when I ditched
Freddie Gibbs this is going to be the
biggest moment of his career I was
really expecting some bars I was like oh
[ __ ] like this thing about to rip me
apart you know what I'm saying so I was
waiting on it you know shout out to
Gunner I'm not sure like we're really
going to Gunner for the bars I mean I
was expecting something I was expected
to you know you know but it was but what
we got was a funny song and you know it
was fun it was a fun moment so shout out
to him for that and you know I hope they
get through that legal situations hey
thoughts bootleg cab here to stop the
interview sorry uh but we gotta pay the
[ __ ] bills and you know not only do
we have to pay the bills but we also
gotta take care of them [ __ ] out there
that's right make sure you go to
bluetooth.com right now you know the
bootleg kept podcast we are presented by
bluetooth proudly I happen to every once
in a while dabble in a little chooski
you know what I'm saying and let me tell
you something my dick thanks me for it
every single time uh so listen if you go
to Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month supply
for free now we're talking the same
active ingredient as Viagra as Cialis
without the awkward doctor's appointment
visit you just go online they get you
taken care of it gets delivered right to
your [ __ ] door in discreet packaging
it's a beautiful thing and how about
this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground raps
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue tree you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole something all
night long bluetooth.com use that promo
code bootleg right now and they will
give you the first month for free so go
do that [ __ ] so you're pretty public
with your lady Fit Mommy who's by the
way a great hang definitely I love her
though she's she's amazing shout out to
you Destiny shout out to Destiny aka the
Fit Mommy uh she said she's gonna
legally change her name to fit Mommy I
was like [ __ ] you crazy as [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I ain't about to be
walking around calling you fit hey fit I
barely found out I barely found out her
name was Destiny like six months ago
right I'll be like just use your [ __ ]
name Destiny Fox you use your name
um but what because you've obviously
been in many situationships since I've
known you what is it about this one that
you make sure that makes you so happy
yeah I'll be me claiming business Kev
but that's what I mean that's what I
mean I mean I mean that's why I said
situation ships
um I don't know man we just you know we
got a good Bond you know and that's
that's first and foremost you got to
[ __ ] with somebody to accept you for you
you know I mean and know that you like
grills know that you you know
you know like to do what you do and you
know have fun and you know and and with
the same you know you got to accept all
of their things and I think it's
acceptance that you know make the bomb
with me and her go so strong you know
what I'm saying that's fair it's love
you know I mean like we ain't never
we never you know of course you know
people argue
get on my [ __ ] nerves I get on her
nerves but uh you know
you get that family bond and you know
that's that's kind of tough to break you
know what I'm saying yeah no I just saw
you guys were you like we're hanging out
with your pops and the kids were there
yeah he's hanging out our Pops kids we
all like family you know what I'm saying
we was just in New York me and my baby
mom shout out to Risa you know what I'm
saying like we was all you know chilling
do the baby mamas get along
uh my baby mama my girlfriend get along
so okay that's cool you know what I'm
saying I mean everybody's cordial if
they see each other you know what I'm
saying they say hi and [ __ ] you know
what I mean they might text me some
stupid [ __ ] they don't be like texting
each other like you know it don't be no
[ __ ] like that everybody be pretty much
smooth for the reason I get the [ __ ]
you get it with all the [ __ ] yeah they
see each other they'd be like hey hey
everything's cordial and I get the
address
that's what that falls into play but I'm
a man dog I'm a king you know and part
of that is you know managing all of
these personalities and yeah doing that
you know we've been doing this since the
beginning of time in Africa my [ __ ] you
know it ain't no big deal you know what
I'm saying it is what it is uh we're
talking about you have an album of the
year but what are your favorite albums
this year that have come out that is not
obviously Triple S uh my favorite album
that came out this year oh hmm
that's a good question uh either between
push or Kendrick one of those two albums
those are probably the two right or Jay
I think jid's up there for me yeah jid's
got a good album too you know I mean he
rap real real good on that [ __ ] I like I
like him but uh young up and coming
for sure he got a lot of years to go in
this [ __ ] you know I'm saying like
that's why that's why I love him he got
20 30 years left to go you know that's a
lot he got it he's young he like 20
something right I don't know how it is
but 20 30 years you got time you got you
got time you got time to do a lot in the
game you know what I mean that's fair do
you feel like being like a veteran right
being kind of like an OG but like now
that you're you're gonna be like a new
artist to A lot of people now I like
that every time I drop an album I feel
like I'm a new artist because there's
going to be people who discover you now
because like now you're on the radio
right you're doing things that like you
hadn't done in your career prior like
right and it's so many artists you know
from you know I don't want to say my era
because this my era but like you know
from my class you know I mean and like
fizzled out already so people don't
expect me to be here I look at like guys
like Kendrick is from your era you know
definitely yeah you know what I'm saying
like uh Cole obviously is from your area
definitely it's a lot of great great
rappers from my uh time in the game yeah
I mean like I come from a a good uh crop
of guys you know what I'm saying and
that that always kept me motivated you
know what I'm saying I was like damn you
know you want to be on the level with
the Kendricks and the codes you know
those are the drinks two guys that set
the mark you know what I mean yeah
definitely yeah was there a feature that
almost happened for this project that
didn't quite make it it's a lot of
almost [ __ ] yeah that happened that
[ __ ] said oh man yeah I'm gonna send
that and uh that's why I [ __ ] that all
[ __ ] I don't need no more all those
features [ __ ] know how to get in
contact with me they can call me I don't
think I ever asked another rapper for a
future ever again I'm good on that [ __ ]
on video I'd like to point out that we
met Drake together and Drake said he'd
get on a record but he also said he'd
give me 50 he made a bet what you did he
said he'd give me fifty thousand dollars
if the Suns went further than the
Warriors two years ago and they did oh
you cashing in on that [ __ ] I don't know
I mean I haven't seen him since damn he
ducking you but you were there I was
right there you can confirmed this he
didn't say that [ __ ] he said I give you
50 Grand if the he said the sons wasn't
going to the finals he did Eric LaRock
was there he did say that so he did say
that Drake owes me 50 bands yeah he do
Drake you do open blue leg calf 50 bands
I can't stand on that I want my
percentage hey you need to give you the
money then I get the ten percent
I'm gonna have you go collect it I'm
gonna go get it for him good that's what
I like that you take a picture with
Katie and Jason Tatum you said you
almost made this happen I almost made
that [ __ ] happen Katie's your guy that's
my guy actually JT my guy too I actually
stopped hating KD because I went to your
birthday at his house and he was a
sweetheart yeah man and he kept
complimenting my Rex Chapman sons of
Jersey he's great man he's a great guy
man he'd be getting a bad rap cause he
like to tweet and talk [ __ ] well how did
you almost make the trade happen because
within my guys and did you convince
Jason Tatum like Jalen Brown like just
look the other way on him because you're
gonna get Katie by everybody you could
have kept Jalen Brown we could have made
it work how
well you're right salary cap would have
been [ __ ] up yeah but you know I mean
like them to my guys I wanted to see
them play together that would have been
dope I mean it would that would have
been like the best so you meet both of
them do you like
actively say yo Boston ain't that bad
I've been there so I told KD that I said
it ain't that bad not everyone's racist
not everybody they got a couple [ __ ]
too in Boston because they got a couple
[ __ ] white [ __ ] dirty foot white
[ __ ] there for sure no no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] they got some
[ __ ] Puerto Ricans or something
yeah but you got to go to Lawrence
Massachusetts to get the Puerto Ricans
they got some bad Dominican [ __ ] too
man come on man you could go come on man
we could work boss I feel like all the
Boston [ __ ] sound like they smoke
gpcs I got a badass Spanish [ __ ] in
Boston that's telling you badass [ __ ]
Boston ain't bad I was gonna give her
the KD if you would have went they don't
all sound like they're from [ __ ] fam
you were gonna give it to Katie I was
gonna get I was a hit man you have my
[ __ ] on the platter man do gift do is
that something you normally do gift hoes
yeah I come from a long line of pimps of
course I've gave out a couple of gifts
nice yeah of course I'd have gifted a
hole or two you know what I mean like
hey my guy's in town take care of him
yeah it's a gift you know what I'm
saying but you've got to pay some gifts
you gotta pay taxes on and [ __ ] right
so that's very good yeah just tip me
um if I gifted you just give me a tip on
the back end would you say that the over
under on on on athletes not liking you
because if a girl is lesser or greater
than three
greater greater for sure oh yeah oh I
feel like all this should be telling
again athletes beautiful that
[ __ ] don't like me because I
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I don't even gotta you
know you know it don't even gotta just
be [ __ ] a [ __ ] I could have just had
coffee with them like a little DM maybe
I don't even know I don't be dmos they
be dming me man I don't even be we don't
even have an Instagram there you go yeah
they find me [ __ ] to find me I like
meeting business out in the world I'm
tired of meeting business on Instagram I
like meeting you outside and I don't be
you know just [ __ ] be trying to kill
me because I had coffee with that [ __ ]
man I don't even be trying to [ __ ] all
the time did you just have coffee with a
girl sometimes yeah yeah I don't even
drink coffee if it's bad she convinced
me to get into Starbucks
I'll be in that [ __ ] and I bring
my [ __ ] with me too shout out to fit
mommy shout out to the Fit Mommy will
she like grab like yeah let's not get
into the Dynamics your relationship it's
obviously one that most that's for
another show most men wish they had yeah
man you guys have a great [ __ ]
arrangement I love her
um would you uh ever do a podcast
Freddie Gibbs we've talked about it many
many times again everybody keep ads look
Funk Flex just asked me to do a podcast
you just asked me to do a podcast Joe
Rogan want me to do a podcast see that's
another thing y'all want me to do out
broken wanted you to do one y'all [ __ ]
won't do an album y'all let me do a
podcast y'all want me to keep acting
y'all want me to take care of these
badass kids what the [ __ ] do you want me
to do don't have time to do it I'm gonna
do all that [ __ ] man I want to do a
podcast why can't I just keep coming on
your podcast
you ever chop it up with Joe Budden I
know you had felt some type of way about
some of the things you may or may not
have said I'm gonna talk to Joe Budden
when I see him
because I don't like playing that not on
some like not on some like rah-rah [ __ ]
just like you know I'm gonna talk to him
when I see him no we definitely because
you guys have a good at least you have a
great relationship he's called you live
on the podcast we cool but we definitely
gonna have to have a concert when I see
him we don't have to have a private
conversation I feel like a lot of the
content and I think that I owe him that
yeah and I think a lot of the context of
like the situation that people have
opinions about they don't that's a
couple of [ __ ] I got to have a
pride it ain't the only one right you
know what I'm saying but yeah I gotta
have we gotta we need to have a private
conversation now I'll just leave it at
that but you know all love and blessings
down tons of merch go pre-order it
you guys shout out to Lambo you guys
probably you guys put out a whole
[ __ ] winter fall summer winter fall
summer line of Alfredo merch the Triple
S merch is looking [ __ ] crazy we got
condoms
all right
[ __ ] what size
they white guy compatible hey first of
all you married you don't need them
first of all you can't give me I just
mean I'm just asking for the fans oh I'm
just saying would you use your own
condoms probably not goddamn right you
would use your own promotional condoms
yeah I will
they might be yeah so
good enough for my fans it's good enough
for me so you'd use the white guy size
condom
see what you did right it ain't gonna
work for long but it'll bust open on
look on if it's necessity you might have
to do what you got to do you gotta do
what you got to do yeah you gotta do
what you gotta do man I don't need no
more kids man that's fair and I'm scared
to go get a what's a man you wanna get a
vasectomy I heard somebody [ __ ] told me
he ain't nothing same after that and I
was like oh good I'll just keep shooting
at the club
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that I heard [ __ ] took that [ __ ]
told me in the gym he was like man I got
it man and when I nut man I'm like it
feels different he just paused for a
second like it feels different but he
was like and I was like
go on [ __ ] tell me what's because I'm
thinking about doing it he's like it's
just filled just empty oh I was like
did you shoot the club up Fred and just
you know keep making millions of dollars
a doctor right yeah so that [ __ ] told
me he said it's a shot you can get yeah
I wouldn't I don't know would you get
the shot I get the shot neuter me God
damn let your brother give you the shot
ah [ __ ] why wouldn't you get your
brother's a doctor let him administer
the shot I don't need him to do it he
got he got women's and stuff that work
for him now to do that [ __ ] I think
they're gonna shoot it in your dick are
they I think that's what it is
your dick go stop work I think this had
to go direct to Dick direct to Dick shot
I think this has to go direct to dick
for this [ __ ] to work but I heard it's a
shot you could get you know my Dibble
and dab I'm not look man I'm good I'm
not having my little kids man for a
while so I'm I'm good I don't think
you're fine I think that's fine I think
pulling out it's been serving me well
there it is man I appreciate you coming
through Brad as always go get the album
Triple S
look if my album
I was about to make a wager with you
but usually I don't do wages on like
[ __ ] like that but uh
but I'm do good I'm gonna do something
good for you Buddha kid that's all I'm
saying okay I'm gonna do something great
real great for you you deserve it thank
you I feel like you don't get enough
credit appreciate that I think my arm
will do this so I'm still waiting for my
uh Alfredo trophy that you made to put
right here you don't have your Alfredo
trophy that's a lassie any supplies and
demands is all on [ __ ] land first of
all [ __ ] Lambo lambo's been promising me
[ __ ] Alfredo merch for two [ __ ]
years I bought like 11 shirts in my
[ __ ] self damn Lambo Lambo is that
Lambo is [ __ ] you know what and y'all
a lot of y'all [ __ ] be trying to like
put that [ __ ] off just an [ __ ] and
cowboy boots maybe trying to put that
[ __ ] on Freddy yeah phrase [ __ ]
they'd be like Lambo so [ __ ] nice
he just delivered a message real quietly
he'd be like hey
you're gonna die that's just that I just
you know what I'm saying I'll let you
know
allegedly no one's dying no no no no no
no not not literally yeah not literally
everyone's alive everybody's gonna stay
alive forever
there it is
fire